how are you doing today sir
i'm doing good how you doing i'm doing
great uh i just want to start by saying
uh uh i'm calling it a film uh
fantastic and your performance uh
fantastic
um uh so i listen i'm a big fan of steve
mcqueen
but even more so after watching two of
these
small axe films um
talk how how did he pull this off
because i know this is supposed to be tv
but the two films i'm calling it films
and the two that i saw are just
fantastic how how did he do this
i don't know i don't know he had it all
planned out by the time i met him um
in in a nice sunny london on a nice
sunny london afternoon and
we went to a restaurant to have lunch he
had he had it all figured out in terms
of
the way he was going to format this um
and i think this is somebody who just
operates from real pure passion for the
art
and for the subject matter um and what
we're seeing is that all of that
mixed with obviously his natural talent
and his professionalism
it's just some dope stuff so you do
still get um
that cinematic experience you know with
these films
um for sure you have to deliver your
performance is fantastic in this
and you have to play someone dealing
with
you know systemic ins um institutional
racism
and someone you know dealing with these
these problems that you're trying to
overcome and you're playing someone very
angry at times
how is it as an actor playing these
scenes and then sort of at the end of
the shooting day are you able to just
shut that off or is that
sort of carrying with you when you're
going home i think i think it depends i
think for scenes like uh when leroy
discovers that his dad's been assaulted
by two police officers and he goes to
visit him in hospital
and that came with a certain deepness
and that came with a certain frustration
that even follows you
into your evening but you know it's part
it is
a better position than being the person
who experiences that firsthand
and that's also something that always
stabilizes me and and and brings you
back because it's just my role to
portray
a truth um and not all troops i've
necessarily walked you know i've never
faced that myself but to be in those
shoes to empathize with that
you know it conveys so much emotions and
then at the same time you have steve
mcqueen
you know who really really is passionate
about making sure that the truth is
captured
to the point where you know my guy's
leaving cameras at the middle of the
room and
allows you to be free and that is that
is the scene
you know and and for me was just a great
experience you know
to collaborate with him in that way i
thought all the performances
um in red white and blue are just so
fantastic especially the stuff with you
and your dad
um did you feel an added pressure
because of the subject matter and
because it was steve
that you just you know more pressure on
yourself to deliver something
great um no not necessarily um
i i think i think i still enjoy my job
which is great
so whenever whenever i do it the passion
to be able to convey truth is is what's
on my mind like i'm dealing with it
much like a student in drama school you
know given a task like that's how i
how it feels i almost forget about the
audience um
and i'm reminded when i see oh this is a
campaign date
you know for a year's time or whatever
and i'm like oh yeah people have to
watch it like i forgot
you know so i i just get to delve into
just the artistry of it and
collaborating and having steve as well
i was just watching him you know
watching him work because i had you know
obviously all had rumors
i want to know how this how this is goes
down so to get a front seat to that was
was dope no completely the thing that i
really uh
uh one of the things that steve does so
well is that he is able to transport you
to another time and place
and it just feels like you're there and
it's
not and it's not easy to do because if
it was easy everyone could do it
um what what did you see firsthand that
maybe
that taught you a little bit about the
way steve puts magic on the screen well
it's
he he keeps he has kept
an energy that even when you go through
drama school some people lose it
and this is the the the creative kid you
know the kid that just
imagines things out of their head and
tries to see it portrayed in
in scenes he's much like very much like
that when something excites him
he's emotional he's off he's laughing
he's he's like oh like he's reacting
like the audience wow
while we're shooting and i just think
he's just very engaging and because he
just has this natural
interest for what he does you know it's
hard not to be that way
too when you're on set and i think
that's a lot of what you're of what
you're seeing and also is it's his
he likes intricate detail you know he'll
tell the cameras to pause before we go
for a shot
just to move a painting in in in one
direction
just because this is just something that
every single thing in the shop
represents
um and to watch that and to see that is
is really cool
um how much as an actor are you looking
at
the the camera and the lenses that are
being used
um and sort of seeing that in in in
or how much are you sort of ignoring
that and just focusing on
what you're the performance i've
definitely
as an actor no but now i produce you
know i'm looking
i'm looking at everything um and it and
it's great to
it's great to see and there's a balance
that comes with it obviously
i have to get to work and get cracking
and make sure i portray a good
performance you know
and don't have you guys writing reviews
that go oh so um i have to fixate on the
job
but it i do i look at everything and on
this specifically
we had so many um members of the of the
crew that i never met before
um and and so i was just very curious to
know who everybody was
very diverse crew too uh you mentioned
producing
um and i spoke to you last time i think
i spoke to you you talked about
producing
um i have to ask is is directing
something that you're looking at
for down the road or is that something
or is it more producing
um for now it's for now it's producing
um
you know we're currently working with
netflix on our deal for
african slate and and i really enjoy
being a part of
um the creative process i think i
would like to be established as a
producer first because i guess
sometimes you feel as an actor
transitioning to producing especially
actors with prominence
it can sometimes just be a a title job
you know and you're not necessarily
raising funds you know you're not
necessarily getting you know
sample treatments every day and trying
to figure out what story to put out but
since i really really want to do this
you know i think i'll establish myself
in producing and if i do want to direct
i'm going to have to show respect to
those that know how to do it and go
through some training process
because i don't know [ __ ]
um i am curious though for producing
um what do you think is going to be
coming up for you what can you talk
about that's getting close to being made
if anything netflix slay
we have one project that we signed on
that were continuously
working on um and other stuff we've got
i've got some
big solid producing news coming but i
can't i can't say nothing about it for
now
but it's dough
is dope proper dough
um i got to stop there and i mean it
seriously though i i
uh you're fantastic in this and and the
film is just so well done
um thank you for your time always a
pleasure